all right I'm Laura Ingram this is
Andrew mangle from Washington tonight
GOP sellouts that's the focus of
tonight's angle
[Music]
now I can't tell you how many
Republicans I've spoken to lately who
are pretty disillusioned and demoralized
election after election they vote some
of them volunteer and they donate to a
party that when push comes to shove
seems to actually detest them
now on big issues like trade and foreign
policy budgets Republican leadership
seems far more comfortable cutting deals
to satisfy Democrats than they are with
working to satisfy their conservative
base
now we saw this Dynamic play out
yesterday when 12 Republican senators
all The Usual Suspects voted for the
deceptively titled respect for Marriage
Act while purporting to safeguard
marital rights of same-sex couples the
law will actually end up gutting the
religious liberty rights across the
country social conservatives of course
are insulted yet they're not really
surprised
and now we just learned this week that
Republicans are going to cave on yet
another huge issue
spending
now on December 16th the government will
run out of money it's convenient how the
deadline always runs right up to
Christmas vacation but all the members
are just desperate to get out of town
well before that deadline Congress can
do one of three things
first it could simply pass nothing and
shut the government down then that would
mean they would cease federal spending
on all non-essential Services you'd
still get your Social Security check
veterans would still get their benefits
Etc now we know they hate doing this
because that move while it is drastic
forces members to stay in town figure it
out and be more accountable for the
obscene amount of spending that it
usually just rubber stamps
second and less drastic a solution for
them would be to pass a temporary
spending bill in the form of what's
called A continuing resolution
this would freeze spending in place for
30 days or for some limited period of
time
now the obvious benefit of this would be
that Republicans would end up being in
control of the house by the time the CR
runs out and thus Republicans would have
much more say over the huge pots of
money that are going to be spent or not
spent at all in some cases
the third option is what both Schumer
and McConnell apparently prefer
and I'm talking about having one giant
or as my son would say ginormous
spending bill that would fund the entire
government for the coming year so no
separate bills in other words for
various departments it would all be in
one just giant bill
this gives Congress huge latitude to
increase spending from 2022 levels which
means billions more for pet causes like
climate change remember the hiring of
those 87 000 IRS agents and of course
never-ending money for Ukraine
now this concession by the master
strategist Mitch McConnell puts
Republicans in a box
with spending questions off the table
they'll lose most of the real leverage
they had to advance their own priorities
in the new year
so at this point why should any of us be
surprised though that McConnell just
announced that quote there's widespread
agreement that would be better off with
an Omnibus than a temporary spending
bill or CR
widespread agreement among whom
certainly not the Republican Party
and tonight we learned via John thune
who's leading these efforts for the GOP
that the appropriators are trading now
negotiating and Shelby Senator Richard
Shelby of Alabama and Patrick Leahy of
Vermont are engaged and we'll see if
they can strike a deal
okay
think about this for a moment
GOP interests are being represented
nothing nothing personal against him but
by Richard Shelby who is an old
establishment guy he's 88 years old and
whose political career is over
that is a joke
now well look Mitch McConnell prefers
these obscene gargantuan spending bills
because it makes his job easier and it
means in the end he won't have to deal
with conservatives quite as much in the
New Year certainly not in the house
now more from this political piece today
McConnell also knows that if he reaches
a deal this month then outgoing speaker
Nancy Pelosi can be trusted to push it
through the house
can the same be said about McCarthy in
January
as one GOP Senator told Politico this
week nobody wants to hand Kevin McCarthy
a grenade with a pin already pulled
wow
he trusts Pelosi more than McCarthy
McConnell
well Washington swamp really just is a
trough with more and more pigs feeding
at it every day Chief among them are our
nation's defense contractors who get you
know basically an ice cream sundae with
a cherry on top from Mitch
McConnell has a price for his
cooperation he's insisting that defense
spending receive a bigger boost than
non-defense spending
okay
you cannot make up how irresponsible
this is now this isn't the 1980s when
our military leaders were reliably
conservative unfailingly traditional
now our military leadership hates us all
should be demanding transparency and
accountability for the nearly 20 billion
dollars worth of military hardware and
humanitarian assistance we've already
sent to Ukraine
he should be demanding an audit of
Pentagon spending there not rubber
stamping what the White House wants in
this new package which by the way
ends up all totaled when you total it
all up with a new supplemental will have
spent 100 billion dollars
in the year 2022 to 2023.
and we have an open border we have tens
of thousands of our own vets living on
gutters Across America and we don't help
them
but a hundred billion dollars to Ukraine
this is just disgusting
this entire episode reminds me of the
infrastructure Fiasco where 19 GOP
Senators decided to sign on with the
Democrats giving Biden that vaunted
bipartisan Victory he talked about
during the midterms
so when they agreed to this McConnell at
all squandered all their leverage that
they could have used to stop the climate
change bill which we all remember passed
with zero Republican votes in August
I mean my God every they say then they
claim like everything on the hill is a
negotiation
well by giving the Dems this win
McConnell ends up avoiding having to
work with the freedom caucus when we're
talking about this this military
spending and this huge Omnibus Bill in
the fall
but my friends the pentagon's budget is
not sacrosanct and our woke military
needs to be subject to more oversight
period
now consider the contract to consider
this contrast there's run and hide
leadership style
of Mitch McConnell with the take no
prisoners approach of someone like Iran
DeSantis now he didn't choose to sell
out in order to keep his seat at the
elites table he fought Disney and he won
these are parents rights important
policies in our state that are very
popular and so they brought this on
themselves all we did was stand up for
what's right and yes they're a big
powerful company but you know what we
stand up for our folks and I don't care
what a burbank-based California company
says about our laws
you got it but here in DC Republicans
don't dare question the Pentagon
keep the government contracts coming
kids never can stop
now over the next year
I bet we're going to see more unnamed
sources talking to the establishment
media complaining that they can't keep
the party unified they're probably going
to be still blaming Trump for that
but if Mitch McConnell's team wants to
blame someone
their boss is going to need to look in
the mirror whether it's a snarky comment
about our Senate candidates or his
willingness to cram through this out of
control pork filled omnibus
McConnell just comes off as totally
disinterested in the people who actually
win his party elections
now the Anglo is praised McConnell
repeatedly as a formidable Fighter for
judicial confirmations
but he uses his talents too often to
help liberals just spend more money
of course being a member of The
Establishment means never having to say
you're sorry the only person who ever
tried to explain this strategy of
working with the Democrats on huge
spending bills was Senator Bill Cassidy
of Louisiana and going to recall that
the angle on that issue obliterated him
you guys got played on this you had to
vote first or agree first they still
haven't shown the text of their
legislation have they Sir
you made it easy for them
Ken McConnell or Cassidy point to one
house or senate seat that the
Republicans won because of their massive
infrastructure bill
now there's going to come a time
probably in the next few years when
Mitch McConnell is going to need
conservative support for his priorities
and his candidates
and that support won't be there because
of this cynical selfish bargain like the
one he's making on this omnibus
in the end ramming through Reckless
spending and stabbing conservatives in
the back is neither smart politics nor
good for America and that's the angle
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else